Will you ever return to "The Bachelorette"?
I mean, I think that's like truthfully
the million dollar question,
but I have to say at least that
that time for me really served me.
So it's taken up a lot of me time for the last four years
that I'm ready to just do the next thing.
Take a break for a minute.
Yeah.
It's not a no, but a pause.
It's a pause.
(audience clapping)
I love it.
Well, we've talked all about dating.
Do you wanna do a quick game
of the Drews and Don'ts of Dating we're calling it?
I thought you'd never ask.
Okay, great, let's do this!
This is the Drews and Don'ts of Dating!
(upbeat music)
All right, first up, someone researching
someone on Instagram before going on a date.
Drew or don't?
That's a Drew.
Oh.
I mean just a little bit.
Oh, no, 'cause I do too.
Oh, okay good.
I actually was relieved.
I was like, "Oh good, so I'm not wrong."
I'm trying to figure out who someone is.
I'm a little nervous, I'm a woman, I feel vulnerable.
I just wanna know, you know, are you a
safe person?
Serial killer.
Yes, thank you!
I got you, I got you.
Are you crae?
No, it's true.
Okay, dating someone 10 years younger, Drew or don't?
Don't, is that bad?
No, I'm totally with you.
Okay, good.
I don't wanna change someone's diapers.
I mean, honey.
I'm sorry, you're 10 years younger?
Do you know what a moron I was 10 years ago?
I wouldn't wanna date me.
That's what I'm trying to say.
10 years ago? Absolutely not.
Oh, God, you learn so much in 10 years!
You have a lot of life to live.
Okay so we're--
We're on the same page.
Yes.
Okay.
Bringing up an ex on the first date.
That's a don't.
Me too!
Why?
I'm like leave that ghost and laundry elsewhere.
No.
Okay.
Dressing to the nines on a first date, Drew or don't?
That's a Drew.
I'm totally game too!
I mean, don't you feel so good?
When you feel good about yourself,
that's when I'm most confident.
Well, okay, so you get ready for a date, I totally agree.
I love any excuse to dress up.
You have partnered up with the skincare brand No7,
and we've actually teamed up today with them as well.
Will you tell me about this partnership?
No7 is all the rage.
People are so loyal to your brand.
I read every single post and magazine,
and I'm a total beauty junkie.
And tell me about working with No7, because they're amazing.
Okay, first of all, now I'm kind of jealous.
'Cause I thought I was bringing the like
UK's best kept skincare secret to you,
because it actually is.
Okay, so it actually happened pretty organically.
So I packed obviously to go to London for about 2 1/2 weeks.
And I was gonna be that girl this trip,
I was gonna unpack everything the second I got there.
Uh huh.
Yeah.
You're making that face 'cause we always say
we're gonna do it, and then we don't do it.
Yeah.
Totally.
So I unpacked everything
and I started getting ready for the day,
and I realized I didn't bring
my moisturizer or my sunscreen.
So I was like, "Okay, cool.
Now I'm gonna go look for something."
So I went to the convenience store,
there's booths out there.
So I went into my booths and I was like,
"Okay, this is the thing.
I don't want to spend so much money on a product
because I forgot it at home.
I want something that's good
that I'm gonna be able to travel with and--"
Accessible.
Exactly.
And I was looking around and I saw like this big display
and it said like No7,
and there was actually a consultant there.
And I was like, "I feel like I've seen your brand before.
I don't know much about it, tell me about it.
I need a moisturizer and sunscreen."
And then she goes off
and she was extremely passionate about this company.
And she was going off about like the science behind it all
and the corrections that it makes to your skin.
And I was like, "Sign me up, I'm in."
I ended up getting the Lift & Luminate
and I have been using it every single day
since I've gotten back, since I was in London.
So what is your very favorite product?
Okay, it's No7 Lift & Luminate Day Cream.
And I love it, because number one,
it hydrates better than moisturizers
that cost 10 times more in the market.
And we all know sometimes when it costs more,
it doesn't mean it works better.
No, it doesn't.
Now, and guess what?
What?
It's 40% off at Walgreens,
right now.
Yes!
Right now!
(audience clapping)
I'm so excited, because talking about this
only leads me to telling you
that everyone in our studio audience is actually going home
with a selection of No7 products today!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)